where were you born paul
1946.
i was born in heightened hospital over
you grew up where right here
yeah uh i growed up on
uh wolf creek over across the hill
that's
alpha holler down here the black top
turned to the right that's that's where
i growed up at
yeah uh mom and dad yeah
yeah they're they both passed away you
know
uh
my dad my dad worked in the coal mines
when we was growing up just teenagers
we tend a big
corn
a whole side of a mountain out of corn
you know and we had to have a milk cow
we had milk cows chickens hogs back then
if you didn't raise what you
eat you would starve almost and my dad
worked in the mines for a dollar hour he
made forty dollars
forty dollars a week into coal mines
that's for i mean uh for eight hours
uh
eight hours a day you got a dollar error
and uh
and we'd take care of uh
everything else with us kids we got up
big enough you know
they uh we attend a big garden
and raise a lot of vegetables
and uh
we'd raise that corn
feeding corn
for hogs and chickens you know well he's
the wrong corn
and uh and daily work in the mines
and we we fared good but
if you didn't raise it you didn't eat by
gosh back then
you couldn't get a whole nothing to eat
my daddy
worked in the mines right now
he'd catch a ride down the road you're
about four mile and he'd cross over to
where
we lived
at and he brought a 50-pound handle lard
for 2.50
cents back then now
2.57 this is the truth now this ain't
just a bear tail
and he'd put it on his back and carry
across the mountain one slot one side of
the mountain
and pack it all the way home after he'd
worked a shift
work on the ground you know
mine
and we we got a long
good but now
back then if you didn't raise it
well you
yeah everything was cheap but you
couldn't get a whole no money couldn't
hardly get a hold of money back then
you have electricity back then how old
were you when you got electricity well i
was about 15.
yeah yeah we had a yeah i'd use coil all
ounce
yeah
and uh
we got along good
it till you get used to them like you
feel like you're in the dark all the
time you don't put much light in there
just a damn light but nothing to see to
get around in and eat
and you bed clothing go to bed
how far are you going to school
i just got a chance to go to fifth grade
i'm telling you just like i said
back then
you we had nine teachers one
one uh
semester you know uh nine years uh
months you know they teach you know out
of the year
and we had nine teachers one time up
some of them wouldn't teach a week
they'd let they would would come back
and
you didn't have much of a chance to get
education now like you do now
no
so it's but now after fifth grade you
went where what do you do start working
yeah yeah i i went
working at the mines when i was 17 years
old
and we loaded it with a shale with a big
shell and we loaded 60 tons
uh 30 tons each man they doubled us up
they had a big old broad car that went
under a
low hang a coal and uh
they'd push it back in there where the
coal pile they cut it with a with a
machine
it had big old bits and it cut out under
that coal
and uh they cut it and shoot it for us
of a night and a day shift would come in
and load it out
and we would load 60 ton between two two
men
and eight hours
and we got 1950 for doing that so a
piece
a day yeah yeah a day yep yep
and then then they went uh joey's
what's called a minor that loads it you
know
love electricity had a big old they
called them digging arms would just
scoop that
coal right up on that conveyor that uh
joey had a bit of a big old conveyor run
to one end that well the tail they
called the tail part you know it's about
drill 15 foot long and they back a
uh buggy right up under it this is
underground yeah on the ground yeah and
uh load it that way
and hip side how they would just rake it
in on the head of that loader on that
conveyor and they'd take it right back
in them cars and they'd haul it outside
and dump it in the table
so when you were a young man were there
options for you other other things you
could have done no no you couldn't
you couldn't make no money and i didn't
have no education when you
you know you have to have so much
education
now to get anything job you know it's
different everything's different ain't
it
but uh just
i had the skill the mind and the willing
mind so
[Music]
i never i never did dread works
i don't right now
i've been
doing something every day going that's
what keeps me going let me tell you
something
when you sit down you'll go down
on the average when you get aging on you
you know what i'm talking about
stop moving not moving not moving use
her to lose it and i sure appreciate the
lord of shape i'm in right now you know
about my breathing never that that heart
doctor couldn't believe i couldn't
believe it over alimony or where it
hazardous my heart doctor
what about your lungs how many years did
you work in the mines work 20. he said
say they run
here on the test on me they do it every
so often about my heart and launch and i
had to go where i
five different times for my
my insurance would cover it you know and
uh
he said your he said your lungs is good
right along with your heart
that ain't been about six months ago and
uh i go to him every three or four
months you know just to visit and uh
he he couldn't couldn't blame my alarm
so that way there was me being that dust
i'd come out there i'd pull clogs of
dirt
coat us were hit caked in my nose
that long right there
i'm telling you now he'd start out and
just keep coming i bet you're not they'd
be as long as your finger you know you
didn't stop them up solid but they they
didn't come out of clod like that where
where i believed this much never did get
on my lungs ain't that something i
breathed it in my nose that must have
been
i'll save my lungs yeah yep
yeah
i i've always been a good person i've
got more friends you wouldn't believe
everybody that knows me i know how to
talk to people and i know when to not to
talk
who to talk to you say a word in some
people they'll just uh have you traveled
have you been around the country
no
no i've preferred ohio i was about the
first time in uh up our dating and i got
some people lived up there back then
it's been
a long time ago it sure been 30 years
ago
my cousin
uh
he he had a sister lived up there and i
went he wanted me to go up there with
him and he'd come snow while we was up
our horse
hit
block people's driveways where they
couldn't get out get out of their
driveways and and
they come
you go to them driveways and they they'd
be glad to get somebody to shovel them
out and we'd shovel them driveways out
they'd give us 10 or 15 you know that's
a whole lot of money back then
yeah they couldn't get back on the main
road out of the driveway from their
house you know and
we don't have no winners like we used to
not now here lately we ain't
we didn't have much snow at all
last winter just a little here and yet
has life gotten harder or easier living
here very well has life gotten harder or
easier since you were a kid
well uh
it's it's say it's got azer things have
changed a lot oh yeah yeah gosh yeah man
yep yep yep
how are things changed
better better uh
you can
get more uh
more things to get food and this and
that that you couldn't get back in or
the coal mining is dried up so that's
not around anymore
well uh uh and that hurt that just
happened for the last year or two
they're haunted right down this creek
here and it's until where they're taking
it they hauled it from that you hear
anybody say anything about blue diamond
across this across the hill here they're
hauling it from over there and then big
trailers down this way
uh it's not telling where it's going
they said that the the coal operator is
getting
300 ton for it
in the temple
right now
it didn't hit there and see i got a
nephew works
works under mine so work leatherwood
they get about two hundred dollars a
shift for eight hours
them coal miners is yep you know we're
getting all surprised there was for the
coal
one of the miners told me that he's
getting a
300 ton for it right now
and the table down hit yeah
what do you make of the
the drug problem that's going on
here well i'll tell you
it's bad
it's bad bad
that
last house up for that fella's been
doing it 25 years and he's never been
rested for it he lives down the road
down here now
about a couple miles a big old stone
store a big old building right in next
to the road level with a road there
about a couple miles down there he lives
down there right now
and selling it right down there right
now and
and there's some guy down there's a law
man law enforcement
he was a game order too
he's never said a word to him but uh
he's got that
that boy's uh uh
niece the one that's selling it
her and he's the game order lives out
they've never he's never said a word to
them
and uh
it's it's everywhere now
this is uh crystal meth hi this is
crystal meth
i know i never did see one well yeah
that's that's what they called it yeah
and
used to
that you could
i have raised it in time i have smoked
some pot
it
it won't hurt you that way i mean
and uh they they
last summer they run a helicopter eight
times over top his house back and forth
to write out hinter
and back they never did do that before
they don't find none they spend an
awesome lot of money he ever was they
found a bunch here again
because nobody won't raise it no more
they know they hunt it's hard and they
put people on me if he's that's that's
what donny did right there
and you know it ain't that bad when
when they make it legal in so many
states
it might be illegal were you
yes legal in california that that's what
i'm saying
there are a whole bunch of states it's
legal in
i've seen people smoking and go about
their business and and
not bother nobody eat it
why
but now that that myth
will go to killing them like flies
that's got so much stuff in it i hear
people talk about what they put in it
and when to get on it they won't get off
of it or can't get off of it once it's
addicted
you know uh
marijuana they use smoker joint maybe
now not smoking
for a while this and that and you you
didn't crave it like that but there's
something to that
to that myth
it's got too bad her name or their
people wouldn't even fool with it
what do you make of the future for the
younger generation growing up here
i tell you what i feel sorry for myself
a young boys you know not know what
they're doing you know what not knowing
how bad it is
it's
that's that's something the the feel bad
about now i'm telling you for the young
generation
and they will get on it
because it's just and they don't try to
do nothing about it they could do more
about it what they
they get a man up there and put him up
50 years if he's caught with it they go
to changing their mind he might just
quit a dealing with it
that boy that man down here is what 25
years nate been caught
they know him just back just like the
bottom of my hand right there that he's
doing it
now it's
it's something scary to think about for
a young generation i mean it
it is
do you have children no no no i've never
been married i've been this woman 20
years
[Laughter]
way too long now you never you never got
married no
no uh i've been staying randall well she
my my nephews
uh
it's got uh
brenda i was married to brenda's girl
and she's got two kids my nephew and
it's all family you know and they they
think more me they do the wrong daddy
he he wasn't no cow don't matter if he
was my nephew the truth is true you know
what i'm saying
and
their mommy and her she's
smart as a tax son she works online and
makes all kinds of money got that right
in the room right in the room in there
yes sir you're you're happy here you've
lived here oh yeah yeah yeah yep yep you
lived a good life
live a good life yes sir
and i'm a person and i don't hold hate
against nobody
just just i mean i'm satisfied any words
i'm mad you don't make no difference
where i'm at i'm satisfied
and that that is that's what makes life
so good you're satisfied anywhere yet
and actually heard people say i went
somewhere it's not as dissatisfied just
that you know what i'm saying
it's not about money
yep because money is not mighty ain't
all the error but you gotta have so much
don't hate that true i mean so much any
house but now money ain't all they are
nope
no sir because this is this is one of
the poorest parts of the country but
if you stay clear of the drugs you know
everyone seems to be living a great life
oh yeah yeah yeah
well see
people would
raise that i've raised some of it at
time
some marijuana but and then here come
that along like that
you know i never
uh i'd but uh smokes a little now then
it it don't affect it it don't affect
you that way
secrets have hurt you worse than
anything this backer that you're seeing
is giving people lung cancer and
everything according to the
to the doctors yeah well alcohol is
probably as destructive as anything well
yeah you buy that anywhere yeah yeah it
and it it makes people mean on alkey
hall that people smoke that pot need as
peaceful as they can be it does them all
way different but i've seen people make
alcohol and they want to start fights
with people that wasn't even bothering
them or nothing
and and uh
i say they ain't too
much to sell for alcohol now since that
mess got out of the straw
it's just scary to think about it now
i'm telling you what the young
generation's going to get into when they
these teenage boys and tell you they
were
you won't do them buddy up with many
people
what were the best times of your life
what was the best decade for you did
what now what was the best decade in
your life
your success
probably
in the 20s when i was in the 20 years
old
i had a little more life about
old
but you wouldn't believe
uh as old as i am
how good my breathing is
i can walk these mountains
i take my time i don't rush i never
smother
i just feel like a young man most the
time but to be that i'd be that old you
see people that old and just fairly are
moving all rolled over a lot of them
you're working every day yeah yeah
just as you as the days comes that i've
been doing something though
you know my grandpa lived to hebrews
102.
his name was felix lewis he's 102
and when he's 85 years old
he he raised his family on the farm
lived on the farm all time
back then and
when he's 85 years old he's he go right
back he had a big field up there about
20 acres cleared black dirt rich is
dirty at wood
and um that's all where where my house
is at right now that
feel that hollow right there
and
you'd see him with his whole hoe and
corn and him in his eighties well he
lived till he's a hundred and two
so we did
what was the hardest time of your life
well up
the hardest time well i
i never have had it too hard you know
good answer i could always
i could always find something to do
find something to eat
i like to fish i go to tennessee fishing
and i've done that for the last 30 years
because the fishing is bitter down
earlier this year
more fish you see common lake
is big yeah that's in kentucky you know
but it's hard to catch him it's the big
you know and i ain't got no boat and we
fish from the bank a lot like that and
we catch more fish from the bank of
sight
yep uh
i take tyler with me there
them them
kids there never has had no daddies they
feel more like i'm their daddy both of
them do that right there and that girl
in our years uncle yeah yeah yep
what's your favorite thing about
appalachia do what now what's your
favorite thing about appalachia
well uh
it's
it's the weather and it's
and the hunting and the fishing while
you talk about about the place yeah yeah
yeah it's beautiful here yeah it's it's
it's heck yeah buddy you won't find no
beautiful place with you
and these timber girls are getting green
like that and
these creeks is clean too what they used
to be that water's just as clear as
branch water you can see the bottom of
it everywhere well it's kind of low now
to you
but back when them strip jobs ever let
everything go in it that's that was hard
on
the wildlife the fishing and everything
you have any regrets in your life
do you have any regrets no no no i've
always been happiest person
i talked to anybody i you wouldn't
believe i've got friends everywhere
that's you same people
they kind of little shy you know about
talking to people strange people you
know
i've never been been that way
from little up
what do you worry about i don't worry
i don't worry about nothing cause
everything ain't gonna be all right you
didn't take long to answer that
uh
i know you used to worry about nothing
cause everything ain't gonna be all
right no way i don't worry about nothing
you know you get upset a few on a few
things but it leaves you you know quick
listen it's a real bad thing you know
like death out of family or
but now
furthest me now
i'm uh
i'm a happy man your childhood is great
sounds like yeah
yeah yeah how big a factor was that in
your
your life how your life panned out well
i just didn't get to go to school you
know what i'm saying we didn't have no
school uh
but you know
i had to quit too quick
back then
where you uh uh
they were you got we had to walk to the
school
about a mile each way
hit the rolling wall it ain't like that
now you know they arrived everywhere to
go to school you see it's changed
you ever you ever wish maybe you'd grown
grown up somewhere else no
no no
no i don't think you'd find no better
place
no
and paul what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life through what now what's the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
well
you know uh
it's
liking people
got friends
that means a lot you have good friends
go go yeah i want foe
just i'm going to talk to everybody i'll
speak if they don't
say a word back i can tell when they
grind out where they don't want to talk
enough i just toast you know what i'm
saying
yep i've got i've got friends good
friends
i want food with
they say i talk to everybody say i know
a lot of people i can pretty well tell
their actions
when does something matter with them
when they're not
right and it's about that way right now
buddy
all right paul thank you so much for
sharing your story
you too i wish you many more wonderful
years same to you thank you
you